mis queridos amigos de visualpolitik
cuando hablamos del ejército ruso en
Ucrania en realidad es como si
estuviéramos hablando de un cuerpo con
tres cabezas y cuáles son estas tres
cabezas atentos por un lado tenemos el
ejército regular del que hemos hablado
ya largo y tendido aquí en visualpolity
por el otro está ramsam cadirov el líder
cheno del que también hemos dado cuenta
aquí en visualpolitik en varios vídeos
un hombre conocido por sus
participaciones Estelares en redes
sociales
[Aplausos]
Pero hay una tercera cabeza en la que
nos vamos a centrar en el vídeo de hoy
hablamos de Jeff Jenny pregosín el dueño
del grupo Wagner la empresa de
mercenarios más importante de Rusia un
oligarca Ruso en toda regla pero no
ligarca muy distinto a los demás porque
a diferencia de los silo bikinis de los
que ya hemos hablado ya en varios vídeos
que son gente con formación y perfil
tecnócrata rigos tiene un pasado mucho
más oscuro cuando preparamos Este vídeo
una de las últimas apariciones públicas
de este oligarca ha sido lanzar este
mensaje al presidente para que el
ejército de Ucrania la población civil
abandonen sus posiciones en bahamut
praxis
el protagonismo que ha adquirido tanto
pligosin como el grupo Wagner en la
guerra es francamente sorprendente ya
que parecen ser los únicos capaces de
lograr algunos avances y algunas
pequeñas victorias en Ucrania pero la
sensación que deja es de falta de
coordinación es como si hubiera tres
ejércitos distintos compitiendo por
conquistar Ucrania y ver quién hace más
méritos ante los ojos de Putin por un
lado tenemos a las fuerzas regulares de
sohigu los cadinovski chechenos de kadir
off o el grupo Wagner es decir el
ejército privado de pregosín Así que la
pregunta que nos hacemos Es por qué
Rusia necesita un ejército privado A qué
se dedica el grupo Wagner quién es y
cuánto poder tienen la rusa de Putin hoy
en visualpolitik vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Aplausos]
Quién quiere un ejército privado
[Música]
la gran pregunta que muchos os estaréis
haciendo es para qué quiere Rusia un
ejército privado si ya tiene el suyo
además normalmente la guerra la libran
los estados por lo que Aparentemente no
tiene ningún sentido sin embargo Rusia
no es el primer país que recurre a los
ejércitos privados mercenarios de hecho
ha habido toda la vida Ya lo sabía
Incluso en tiempos de Alejandro Magno
pero no nos vayamos tan lejos hablemos
de marzo de 2014 cuando Rusia se
anexionó la Península de crimea aquello
no tuvo nada que ver con lo que todos
asociamos con una invasión en este
territorio a orillas del mar Negro
aparecieron de repente los famosos
hombrecitos verdes hablamos de soldados
sin insignias ni distintivos que el
kremlin nos quiso hacer creer que era
una especie de simpatizantes de la causa
rusa civiles que habían tomado las armas
para llevar a cabo la anexión Obviamente
todos los identificamos como los
soldados rusos puesto que servían a los
intereses de Putin de hecho la actual
guerra en Ucrania ha confirmado estas
sospechas O tal vez no
a día de hoy se piensa que los pequeños
hombres verdes eran una mezcla de
algunos agentes de las fuerzas de
operaciones especiales y otras unidades
de servicio de inteligencia militar de
las fuerzas armadas rusas junto con
personal contratado del grupo Wagner no
eran por tanto fuerzas regulares de
ningún ejército oficial sino una mezcla
de espías y Mercenarios
aquí tenéis la principal razón por la
que cada vez más países están
recurriendo a los ejércitos privados la
negación verosímil es decir que las
autoridades siempre pueden negar la
implicación directa del estado en las
acciones de estos mercenarios
especialmente en aquellas de marcado
carácter clandestino por ejemplo el caso
de los hombrecillos verdes en crimea si
aquella operación no hubiera salido bien
El kremlin hubiera intentado decirnos
que ellos no tenían nada que ver o que
eso era gente que actuaba de forma
aislada y gracias a que la anexión de
crimea no se vio como una agresión
armada de Putin a Rusia le salió
prácticamente gratis de hecho recordáis
donde se celebró el mundial de fútbol en
2018 Pues eso la cuestión es que los
ejércitos privados están de moda y
algunos estará pensando Oh Dios mío el
neoliberalismo ha llegado al mundo
militar matones que se venden al mejor
postor con la de Tiranos que hay por el
mundo pues esperad un momento porque
igual que Rusia recurre a Wagner Estados
Unidos también ha utilizado a los
blackwaters ahora llamados Academy
en la guerra de la administración de
George Bush utilizó intensamente los
servicios de corporaciones militares
privadas como blackwater para aumentar
rápidamente La Presencia militar
estadounidense a medida que la situación
empeoraba Claro que algunas
informaciones sobre supuestos abusos
perpetrados por algunas fuerzas armadas
de seguridad privada contribuyeron a que
la opinión pública les percibiera como
unos mercenarios irresponsables lo que
habría un polémico debate sobre su
supervisión y su falta de rendición de
cuentas
[Música]
lo que ha hecho Estados Unidos con los
blackwater en Irak o en Afganistán habla
directamente de otra de las grandes
ventajas que ofrecen estas compañías
militares la flexibilidad un ejército
privado lo puedes utilizar en cualquier
momento Si quieres usar tu ejército por
ejemplo en un país extranjero
seguramente tendrás que votarlo en el
parlamento defenderlo ante la opinión
pública y sacar alguna ley
[Música]
todo esto tiene un coste político y la
gente puede protestar obviamente esto
importa más en una democracia pero
incluso Aunque un tipo tan autoritario
como Putin quisiera ser opaco para
utilizar el ejército regular ruso en el
extranjero su gobierno tiene que
informar a la duma en cambio con una
empresa privada Putin no tiene más que
el teléfono y mandarles a donde
haga falta Así es como actuaron por
ejemplo en Siria donde el grupo Wagner
estaba peleando con las fuerzas de alasd
en primera línea Mirad esta noticia del
año 2018 el kremlin se desmarca de las
informaciones sobre muertes de
mercenarios en Siria en este titular que
acabamos de ver se junta todo
flexibilidad negación verosímil y otra
ventaja muy importante Las bajas no
cuentan igual si son del ejército
regular que si son de una empresa
privada y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos a ver Fonseca los muertos muertos
son Y sí tenéis razón pero para la
opinión pública no son lo mismo porque
si cae un marine es la Casa Blanca la
que tiene que rendir cuentas pero sí que
es un blackwater no y por supuesto otro
punto a favor de los ejércitos privados
es el mismo que el de cualquier otra
forma de colaboración público privada la
subcontratas buscan ser las más
competitivas para así llevarse un
contrato público en el caso de las
empresas militares privadas sucede
Exactamente lo mismo
también podemos hablar de la experiencia
antes de la invasión de Ucrania
Prácticamente la última vez que había
entrado en combate un soldado del
ejército regular de Rusia había sido
Durante los cinco días que duró el
conflicto contra Georgia de hace 15 años
por su parte uno de Wagner es posible
que haya estado en los últimos años
combatiendo en Siria Líbano malío la
República centroafricana
[Música]
de este modo estamos hablando de otra de
las grandes ventajas de los ejércitos
privados que sus miembros tienen mucha
más experiencia en primera línea que un
soldado regular de hecho muchos de los
integrantes del grupo Wagner son
antiguos miembros del ejército ruso e
incluso son veteranos de Las Guerras
chechenas Así que todos estos son los
motivos por los que están floreciendo
las empresas privadas militares a lo
largo del mundo y especialmente en Rusia
en ocasiones interesa la negación
verosímil la falta de rendición de
cuentas la mayor flexibilidad para
realizar misiones semi clandestinas y
tener tropas más experimentadas todo
esto suena fantástico verdad pues hay un
problema la Constitución rusa prohíbe la
creación de destacamentos armados de
carácter privados así La pregunta es
cómo Putin si has saltado las propias
leyes rusas Quién ha sido el tonto útil
que lo ha hecho pues bien Ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
el chef de Putin
a principios de la década pasada Rusia
empezó a mostrar interés por las
empresas militares privadas la cuestión
es que como acabamos de ver Rusia no las
permite incluso está penado servir como
Mercenario aún así el propio Putin sabía
que necesitaba algo como un ejército
privado y en la pista de lo que iban a
hacer nos puso Dimitri Robotín por aquel
entonces el viceprimer ministro ruso
estamos pensando si nuestro dinero
fluirá para financiar empresas militares
de seguridad privada extranjeras o
consideraremos la viabilidad de crear
tales empresas dentro de la propia Rusia
y dar un paso en esta dirección Dimitri
dice Primer Ministro de Rusia en 2012 La
pregunta es quién estaba dispuesto a
hacer algo flagrantemente ilegal en
Rusia los en lobiquis que rodean a Putin
Por supuesto que no estaban por la labor
porque tenían demasiadas cosas que
perder Así que hacía falta un tonto útil
alguien con hambre de dinero y poco
miedo a saltarse la ley y esa persona
estaba vendiendo perritos calientes en
las calles de San Petersburgo os
presento
[Música]
después de pasar buena parte de los años
80 en la cárcel un puesto de comida
callejera fue el comienzo de todo un
imperio gastronómico la caída de la
unión soviética y la transición al
capitalismo de Rusia ofreció nuevas
oportunidades a prigó sin que con el
tiempo habría restaurantes de lujo como
el New Island que se convirtió
rápidamente en el favorito de Vladimir
Putin su cercanía con el presidente ruso
fue el origen de su fama hasta el punto
de ser conocido como el chef de Putin
ahora bien una cosa es que tu estrogonov
este de muerte y otra muy distintas que
acaba siendo el jefe de Los mercenarios
rusos Pero por qué se fijaron los
sylobiquí en un oligarca como prigo sin
para montar un ejército privado la
respuesta la encontramos en el grupo
Concord es una empresa de catering que
disfruta prácticamente de un monopolio
en los comedores escolares de Moscú así
como en hospitales y cuarteles rusos
esta fue la vía por la que pregosim puso
en marcha al grupo Wagner cuando desde
luego en 2014 ya estaban en crimea y en
la guerra separatista del Don vast que
comenzó después
los datos empresariales públicos nos dan
muchas pistas el volumen de servicios
prestados por las empresas relacionadas
con brigosin y el Ministerio de defensa
ruso pasó atentos de 11 millones de
euros en 2014 a mil millones de euros en
2015 y esto no es porque priego sin
empezar a darle caviar a La tropa además
el campamento donde Se entrena el grupo
Wagner se ubica en una parcela que
pertenece al Ministerio de defensa y que
está en malking cerca de krasnodar por
tanto los vínculos del kremlin con
Wagner son evidentes
para financiar un ejército privado y
ahora les está generando otro tipo de
problemas atentos como saben San
Petersburgo está dirigido por Una
Pandilla de personas que se llenan los
bolsillos y no cumplen su palabra
para decir lo que quiera incluso para
arremeter contra los propios y lo
Vikings se ha convertido en alguien
absolutamente incontrolable
[Música]
al frente de Wagner pregosín infunde
auténtico miedo y no es para menos
viendo el historial de sus mercenarios
por medio mundo su especialidad son las
torturas salvajes y las ejecuciones
extrajudiciales y encima se graban en
vídeo para alardear y os aseguro que a
su lado quentin tarantino es Sofía
coppola y sí habéis oído bien he dicho
medio mundo porque claro cuando tienes
un ejército privado no lo utiliza solo
para crimea y el donbash atentos
mercenarios rusos buscan oro y siembran
el caos en África Central la República
centroafricana lleva 10 años inmersa en
una guerra civil su presidente recurrió
al grupo Wagner para instruir a sus
tropas y garantizar a su seguridad
personal A cambio les ofreció no dinero
sino recursos naturales por cierto que
sobre la República centroafricana os
hemos hablado hace muy poco en not news
que como sabéis es nuestro boletín
gratuito para toda la comunidad de
visualpolitik os enviaremos cada semana
dos boletines analizando todos los
principales acontecimientos que explican
la actualidad mundial desde la política
al mundo de la economía pasando por el
de las grandes finanzas qué decís
todavía no lo conocéis pues ya estáis
tardando podéis suscribiros en not
news.com Y si os gusta lo que hacemos y
queréis apoyarnos y encima recibir más
boletines merchandising y un montón de
cosas que estamos preparando podéis
sumarlos también a nuestra comunidad en
patreon os dejamos todos los enlaces en
la descripción y dicho esto continuamos
porque hay mucho más está lo mencionado
en Siria donde al azar les prometía nada
menos que el 25% de los campos
petroleros que liberaran de manos de los
kurdos apoyados por Estados Unidos pero
también está Libia mozambique Sudán en
el kremlin están encantados porque
Wagner está aumentando la influencia
rusa sobre África en detrimento de otras
potencias como Francia y al igual que
crece la influencia rusa los negocios de
pregosín no paran de crecer
acostumbrados a ver titulares de este
tipo como Los mercenarios rusos están
apoderando del comercio de diamantes
africanos tal es el meteórico ascenso de
este tal pregodín que en la propia Rusia
está generando preocupación entre los
siloviki
[Música]
recordad que pregosín no es uno de ellos
y genera recelos porque los Silvi lo ven
como un antiguo delincuente reconvertido
en oligarca Y eso explica que su
relación esté repleta de altibajos la
prueba es que su éxito comenzó en San
Petersburgo ciudad dominada por los
shilobiquí pero sin embargo sus negocios
empresariales han prosperado en Moscú
por ello priego sin siempre ha sido muy
crítico con las autoridades de San
Petersburgo más aún desde el pasado
verano cuando megaline una de sus
empresas se quedó fuera del desarrollo
de coscaya un macroproyecto que ahora
ejecutará una empresa vinculada a las
pro megalaine asegura que es morning
rescindió el acuerdo sobre el desarrollo
del territorio gorskaya es la sede del
gobernador de San Petersburgo
actualmente está ocupada por Alexander
bgloff un protegido de sergeikienko que
es la mano derecha de Putin para la
política interior rusa por eso vigosin
se está implicando tanto en la Guerra de
Ucrania victorias en Ucrania se traducen
en más influencia en el kremlin pero
también en más enemigos atentos
[Música]
pelea de gallos
a estas alturas no hace falta saber
mucho sobre la guerra sobre todo en su
primera fase para entender que las cosas
no han ido exactamente como el kremlin
había planeado Rusia intentó tomar gif
por la vía rápida y fracasó que hizo
entonces Putin pues al mes y medio de
invadir Ucrania recurrió al grupo Wagner
Putin conoce al deciyo el historial de
Wagner y sabe que sus hombres están
curtidos en mil batallas el problema es
que el chef de Putin Se ha guardado sus
mejores ingredientes y a Ucrania ha
enviado a miles de convictos básicamente
con una promesa libertad o muerte
cierto
a la vista de los continuos fracasos de
su ejército Putin le dio Wagner libertad
de actuación después del verano Fue
entonces cuandoen recurrió a los
veteranos de Wagner para llevarles a
Ucrania a liderar los miles de
mercenarios recién reclutados
desplegados en el frente después de un
único mes de adiestramiento nos
encontramos por tanto con tres cabezas
al frente de las fuerzas rusas
[Música]
en primer lugar está el ejército ruso
dirigido por silovikis de manual como el
ministro soy gu y el General
valeriggerassimov Será muy tecnócratas
pero están fracasando después tenemos a
los kadieroski dirigidos por el líder
off tampoco pueden presumir de grandes
victorias y finalmente tenemos al grupo
Wagner que son los únicos que sí pueden
mostrar algunos resultados sí es cierto
peleando metro a metro pero las fuerzas
rusas de pregosín han empezado a
recuperar terreno en el donbas y
pregosín no ha dudado en atribuir todo
el mérito a sus mercenarios incluso a
criticar abiertamente al gobierno y no
crees que hablamos de críticas pequeñas
aquí podéis escucharle mientras Los
mercenarios de Wagner practican tiro con
dos generales rusos en la Diana
los daños transpartado
estas tres cabezas de las fuerzas rusas
están compitiendo a cara de perro para
hacer méritos ante Putin el presidente
ruso ha pensado pues Oye mientras estos
luchan entre ellos no se ponen a
discutir si yo soy el que debe seguir
siendo líder supremo de esta forma están
motivados para entregar victorias a
Rusia y efectivamente eso es lo que está
sucediendo las victorias más recientes
de Rusia en la Guerra de Ucrania han
llegado de la mano de prigosin ahí está
soledad y así parece que será con
bahamut ahora bien para cortar la
creciente influencia de enero el kremlin
relevó como comandante en jefe para
Ucrania a ser gay surovikin general
próximo a Wagner en su lugar colocaron
al propio
además el kremlink ya no permite a
pregosín reclutar a las cárceles todo
esto explica los ataques que pregosín
está lanzando contra el gobierno Ruso y
los shilobiquí ve como su influencia
sobre Putin está en peligro así que ya
veremos qué sucede en los próximos meses
imaginad que dirá pregosín si sigue
siendo el único que consigue victorias
para Rusia pero ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros creéis que el grupo Wagner
será de verdad decisivo para decantar la
guerra puede ser pregosín el su cesor de
Putin podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios y como siempre si os
ha resultado interesante el vídeo dadle
a like y no olvidéis suscribiros a
visualpolitik Ah importante y no
olvidéis echarle un vistazo a not
news.com un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]